c'était bien laurence vous qui passez
vos après midi au téléphone confinés
dans votre bureau
free j'ai une bonne nouvelle à vous
annoncer désormais vous allez pouvoir
faire du shopping téléphone à la main
c'est nouveau ça vient de sortir et
vergers à strasbourg la capitale
alsacienne est à l'avant-garde dans le
domaine des télécoms depuis un an 2000
volontaires tester le téléphone portable
be bop
aujourd'hui les mises en vente et il
coûte un peu moins de 2000 francs
kristin ross c'était il ya un peu plus
d'un an
lancement à strasbourg du bebop le
premier téléphone de poche français
téléphoner en pleine rue jusqu'au bout
du monde c'est un nouvel espace de
liberté le succès est immédiat mais
seuls 2000 privilégiés vont tester le
réseau de bornes installées dans le
centre ville après un an d'utilisation
75% d'entre eux sont satisfaits
aujourd'hui france télécom se lance dans
la commercialisation l'appareil le
terminal coûtera 1890 francs la
tarification sur la tarification du
réseau normal plus ce 83 centimes par
minute et il ya un abonnement qui s'y
rajoutent de 54 ans 50 donc par mois
tirez-en klein vous ouvrez clapper
et vous appuyez sur le marché et ce
matin dans une des agences
strasbourgeoise de france télécom une
demi douzaine de clients trois au moins
sont repartis avec un bebop bas j'ai
peur que mon service attendant je
l'aurais peut acheter
oui et l'utiliser dans quelles
circonstances aux banques commerciales
est pris mais c'est surtout le confort
un confort supplémentaire de
communication qu'est ce qu'un gadget tôt
en effet l'ensemble du centre ville
ainsi que l'aéroport et toutes les
mairies de la communauté urbaine font
partie des zones d'appel quant aux
parisiens ils devront encore patienter
jusqu'au mois de mai pour découvrir le
charme du bebop